gut nahrungsmittel horten bin ich schon
dabei aber ich möchte in diesen zeiten
auch sicher wohnen ich glaube ich
brauche einen bunker ja ja ja
die haben eigentlich sicherer bunker
echt was wo das ist jesus christus ist
unser punkt her acht den bunker wurde im
toro rosso lebensmittel was der
menschheit zu kommen hallo ich hätte
gerne cola light lait gemischte tüte für
250 und so platz im bunker mein chef
mit dem vielleicht noch hinter
regimechef ja 52
naja sagen wir mal so so schick ist
nicht sieht aus wie eine ganz normale
schultoilette
sowie die heute aussehen ja das land die
schultoiletten genau also ist wirklich
ihre bunker stehen im internet
einzukaufen weil ich bin gerade auf der
suche ich habe auch mehr was an die
seite gelegt ja zurzeit wird ja darüber
geredet und das ist ja wurden sogar
objekte wieder aus
daneben möchte wurde so berichtet ja
aber zurzeit ist es ja nicht nur der
bunte interesse hat so ein mann ich habe
erstaunlicher war es in den letzten in
der letzten woche schon diverse anfragen
bekommen tatsächlich ich denn im notfall
auch räume zur verfügung stellen würde
hört sich alles so lustig an naja aber
vor jahren hat gut mir immer gesagt was
willst du denn mit dem ruhm kann
so sehen bunker in düsseldorf aus
zumindest wenn sie luxuriös saniert
wurden sollten die raketen vorbeikommen
man kann sie schon von weitem sehen oh
mein gott das ist ja wunderschön
das ist genau mein geschmack
danke wir haben wirklich an allen vier
seiten komplett verglasung ein bisschen
new yorker loft stil genau die badewanne
war das erste das dach gehoben haben
sich 15 tonnen gott und haben wir eben
baum sozusagen das gebäude um die beiden
herum gebaut wie teuer wäre das so wenn
ich das jetzt kaufe so ist dann kann ich
sagen ich hab dich darüber nachgedacht
das ist ein eigenbedarf gedacht
dass sie wohnen jetzt hier allein meine
partnerin genau was sie haben auch schon
partnerin also ja ich könnte mich da
jetzt nicht irgendwie noch so einen
schicken oder
es gibt ja auch so andere polier
konzepte wo man auch zu dritt
aber ich dachte aber nicht ausmachen
könnten sie mir zur not unterschlupf
gewähren das ist meine frage heute
würden sie mir unterschlupf gewähren
aber
wir sprechen mit andreas klink er hat
einen master in disaster klingt komisch
ist aber so hallo eck links und herr van
der horst wie teuer wäre das denn wenn
man so alle vom bunker funktionstüchtig
halten würde group können wir können wir
die schweizer fragen sie sagen ich habe
über 100 prozent quote aber man muss
sagen ganz ernsthaft die die schweizer
sind auf kriegerische ereignisse sondern
auch auf naturkatastrophen auf
lieferketten unterbrechungen
auf ausfall von
lebensmittelversorgung deutlich deutlich
besser vorbereitet als wir
u
bahnstation köln-kalk hinter einer
unscheinbaren stalltür lauert vielleicht
die lösung
sondern schön
kuschelig ja auch die wandfarbe sommer
hat die wand war von psychologen
entwickeln lassen ein mit der
größtmöglichen beruhigungs wirkte
ehrlich das ist der spezielle farben die
leute zu beruhigen genau aber sollte man
so vielleicht das innere des kremls
ballstreichler wahrscheinlich ja unter
wahrscheinlich
zu hoch ist ihr hallo hallo wie lange
sind sie denn schon in einem bunker wie
viele jahrzehnte
vielleicht vergessen die frauen hier mal
reingucken 24 betten beziehungsweise
sitzplätze
da würde ich mir das direkt schon mal
reserviert für den erhalt gute deutsche
man ja ja ich würde sagen ich nehme mir
angebot an ich gehe in das kabuff
machen wir das sie wollen sich dann
natürlich ja alles klar dann würde ich
sagen ab ins kabuff wo wohnen sie drüben
und ich gebe zurück nach köln da lag ich
habe ich habe platz gefunden
ja das war gut leckere konzerns
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist nicht so viele abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten